Trascrizione: camilla bisesti
Revisore: Nicoletta Pedrana
Chiunque ha un lavoro, ha in mente
soprattutto una domanda inizialmente:
chi è il mio datore di lavoro?
Se vogliamo dirla brutalmente:
chi mi paga?
Più elegantemente possiamo dire:
chi è il mio stakeholder? Chi sono
i miei stakeholders?
E guardate, può non essere
una domanda banale.
È chiaro che se lavori in uno studio
dentistico e c’è il dentista, il titolare
e tu, quello [lo stakeholder] è  lui.
Però, per esempio, se lavorate in
una grande multinazionale,
chi è il capo?
È il tuo capo?
Sono gli azionisti? Quali azionisti?
E cominciano le complicazioni.
Se sei il sindaco di Milano
è abbastanza complicato.
Arriverò alla risposta che mi sono dato
ma fatemi fare un piccolo salto indietro:
Se vuoi imparare tante cose nella vita,
nelle professioni,
nella politica in particolare,
secondo me devi guardare agli Stati Uniti.
Lì eravamo in epoca pre-covid
ma anche pre-primarie democratiche,
allora io ho chiamato
il nostro ambasciatore e ho gli ho detto:
“mi organizzi alcuni incontri
con quelli che possono essere
i potenziali candidati?”
Alcuni li conoscevo, sono molto amico
di Eric Garcetti, sindaco di Los Angeles,
che è stato candidato per un pò.
Sono molto amico di Mike Bloomberg.
Alcuni non li conoscevo. Ho fatto questo
giro, e i politici in America hanno
in mente due cose: la prima cosa
è chi li finanzia.
E lì è molto trasparente, molto chiaro.
La seconda domanda è: chi mi vota?
E ovviamente sono mondi diversi.
C’era una cosa però che mi ha fatto
riflettere, può essere banale ma non lo è.
Tutti mi hanno detto una cosa: “guarda, se
vuoi essere candidato alle primarie,
se vuoi vincere le primarie democratiche,
devi parlare ai giovani
e i giovani ascoltano solo una cosa:
ambiente”.
Una.
Tornato a casa, abbiamo poi vissuto
l’epoca del Covid,
ho deciso di ricandidarmi e mi sono fatto
questa domanda. E guardate, è chiaro che
i miei stakeholders siete tutti voi,
è chiaro che io, la nostra comunità,
dobbiamo portare rispetto agli anziani
che hanno fatto la loro parte,
ma sono i giovani
a cui noi dobbiamo guardare
se realisticamente vogliamo
portare la città
in un mondo più verde, più giusto. Ma non
solo perché loro sono gli uomini e le
donne del futuro, ma perché possono
essere i nostri alleati.
Alla fine anche la politica è un processo
creativo.
È un processo teso a creare le condizioni
del futuro.
E di nuovo durante il covid
l’organizzazione di cui Milano
e io facciamo parte, la C40, mi ha chiesto
di essere a capo di questa task force.
Perché non si voleva solamente subire
il covid,
ma si voleva lavorare
in queste circostanze
per trovare la formula con
cui ne saremmo usciti e la task force
si chiamava letteralmente “For a Green
and cJust Recovey”. Non esiste verde,
non esiste un’idea verde senza l’idea
di una giustizia sociale.
Questo è evidente anche perché qualunque
azione noi facciamo, non è detto
che le due cose si combinino. Cioè se noi
istituiamo l’area B, per cui tu
con una macchina più inquinante
non entri in città,
è un’operazione giusta dal punto di vista
ambientale; ma dal punto di vista sociale
è rischiosa per chi normalmente
ha un’auto vecchia e non la può cambiare.
Ma rimane il fatto che in tutto ciò devono
essere i giovani a darci una mano,
soni i nostri alleati. Non solo perché
il mondo sarà loro ma perché
sono i nostri alleati.
25 anni fa a Milano c'erano
60 auto ogni 100 abitanti.
Oggi siamo a 51 e noi dobbiamo
realisticamente andare a 40. Dobbiamo
andare a 40 e si può fare, in una decina
d’anni, in una dozzina di anni
Ma perché loro sono gli alleati?
Quando avevo 18 anni era meglio
pigliare una coltellata
che non avere la macchina.
Ma oggi non è così .
Oggi quasi è un po’ snob
non aver la macchina.
In questo senso
e non solo in questo sono degli alleati.
Le città sono alla frontiera
del progresso. Io mi sento progressista.
Guardate che progresso è una parola
che fino ad alcune decadi fa
metteva d’accordo tutti.
Tu dicevi progresso e tutti dicevano sì .
Poi questo termine, quest’idea ha vissuto
una profonda crisi perché è stata
associata a una corsa sciocca ai consumi,
all’insostenibilità ma noi dobbiamo
credere nel progresso,
un progresso diverso.
E in questo senso le città hanno
questa responsabilità.
Se in Italia nascerà qualcosa di buono,
io sono convinto che nascerà a Milano.
E è per questo che io sono qua, per questo
che io conto anche sulla collaborazione
di tutti voi che non siete qua
semplicemente a sentire ma siete qua
perché siete partecipi di questo processo.
Noi possiamo essere sufficientemente
ottimisti perché alcune cose
stanno cambiando.
Vi racconto di un paio di sondaggi,
il primo ha commissionato il secondo
l’ho visto. Il primo l’ho
commissionato quando stavo all’inizio
della campagna elettorale. Allora ho preso
Ipso, e non era tanto se avrei vinto
o meno, poi non c’era neanche
l’avversario per cui...
Ma ho cercato un pò di sfrugugliare
rispetto ai temi più scottanti.
C’erano due domande sulle piste ciclabili
che associate dicevano tutto.
La prima domanda è: tu sei favorevole
ad avere ancora più piste ciclabili?
Risposta: il 56 per cento
sì, e non era scontato.
Ma guardate la seconda:
usi le piste ciclabili? 20 per cento sì .
Allora cosa vuol dire?
Vuol dire che questi processi virtuosi
nascono nelle città .
Perché noi siamo naturalmente generosi ed
esigenti ma abbiamo la disponibilità ad
essere fattori di cambiamento.
Secondo sondaggio, fatto da C40 in
questi giorni alla popolazione europea:
viene fuori che il 90 %
dei cittadini europei sono favorevoli
al che i grandi investimenti europei siano
indirizzati alle questioni ambientali.
Ora anche questo magari è scontato però
noi dobbiamo veramente, a questo punto,
immaginare che questa associazione di
una realtà più verde, più giusta
sia la nostra ambizione.
Ci vorrà del tempo.
Io ho pregi e difetti, non dico bugie
e non ho la bacchetta magica.
Non dico cose, non prometto cose
che non posso promettere.
Ma posso promettere di avere in testa,
di avere con me persone capaci,
di avere con me
una cittadinanza attiva, che potrà
portare Milano ad essere la città guida.
Perché guardate, se noi faremo
le cose per bene,
altri ci imiteranno. Se noi faremo
le cose per bene, altri ci imiteranno.
E ultimissima cosa.
Chi come me ha un po’ di anni di più,
si è sentito dire nel passato: sì ma la
gente alla fine non vorrà vivere
nelle città troppo complesse,
è un casino, inquinate.
La contemporaneità si è occupata di dirci
che non è così:
la gente vuole vivere in città.
Però c’è un fatto: che le vuole diverse.
Lavoriamoci. Grazie.